in this video i'm going to show you part
two of how to create a vintage b-movie
title that will make your friends think
you're a hollywood pro
hi there my name is cameron with motion
science and this is the second video in
a series of videos where i'm teaching
you how to create an eye-catching
attention-grabbing sci-fi b-movie title
with a little bit of creativity and some
simple tips you'll be able to come up
with your own title that will make
people excited to see your film so let's
get started on part two so here's what
we created last time in part one but now
we're ready to add some typography to
this animation so what i like to do is
search out a font specific to my project
and for this particular instance i
searched b movie font and a lot of
different fonts came up as you can see
here here's one example from font space
charmling was one that i really played
around with a lot and enjoyed what i
ended up really loving a lot was this
font called lugosi so what we're going
to do is hit our type tool here and
we're going to type in our title we're
going to call this
monsters from outer space so let's go
ahead and center this up a little bit
something like so hit p for position
shift s for scale set a keyframe and
let's make sure that's at two seconds
there we go go back to the gamer
timeline and we're gonna scale this down
to about 25
and we're going to bring this
somewhere down in here something like
that we'll hide it later on we're going
to select our end keyframes right click
keyframe assistant easy ease in and
let's preview this and let's see how
it's looking yeah it's starting to get
that kind of quirky b-movie feel to it
let's take this a step further let's add
a light to our scene i'm going to go up
to layer new light and i'm going to
select point light i like to work that a
lot you can also work with a spotlight
here i'll turn the intensity down to
about 85 percent and it's not really
doing much yet i'm trying to get some
more visual interest from the asteroids
here especially when they're really
close to the camera so what i need to do
is go into my particle systems we're
gonna go to the lighting tab here enable
lighting and we're going to change it
from natural to
none ae and then we're going to position
our light so that it lights these
asteroids in an interesting but good way
i'm going to hit p for position and i'm
just going to take the z value and just
kind of drag it back you can see as i
drag it back it's lighting up these
asteroids here in the background but
then making these foreground ones still
kind of dark let's go ahead and hit
shift command h so we can see our light
there yeah and so that's already more
interesting because these these
asteroids here in the front are just
dark
until they get to about here i want them
to be light it's like the z channel and
kind of just pull this light back even
further i'm really looking at this one
here wondering why it's still dark but
there it's it's into the light right
there next let's add a ufo i went to one
of my favorite sites which is envato
elements and i typed in ufo and you can
see there's some stock video here here's
a rotating ufo that you could use this
very easily you could use just a
photograph of a ufo and cut it out
but i really like there's this 3d option
here where i can click and if i click on
view 360 render i can position it like
so
and i can export each of these positions
as a png file so i just went ahead and
selected about four positions so i can
see that you can see there's some
texture that moves across the top here
you can also see a little bit of
variance here at the bottom with the
shape
moving so i exported about four of these
pngs so i've got one two three four five
select them all and drop them into a new
composition here we're gonna sequence
these layers i want each of these stills
to be let's say two two frames long
click okay one thing i do need to be
aware of here if i go to alpha channel
you're gonna see that there's a shadow
here in the alpha channel that's because
within envato elements you can see
there's a shadow in the image you can
download these as photoshop files and
delete that shadow i wanted to keep it
as simple as possible so i downloaded a
png that includes the shadow all i have
to do is select my first layer go to my
mask tool and just draw a mask over the
top here and then with that mask
selected
command c to copy and then select all
these command d to paste
and now i can see it's rotating without
a shadow so we'll go back to rgb so
let's go ahead and let's rename this
pre-comparables call this ufo
rotate
and back here in our main composition
now we've got ufo rotate we're going to
bring it down we are going to make it 3d
so that reacts the environment and it
reacts to the light that's super super
important one thing you'll notice is
that the ufo disappears right here
because that's where the composition
ends what we can do here is we can go
ahead and go to layer
[Music]
time enable time remapping and we can
alter option click on that timing map go
to our property
loop out then we're going to go ahead
and extend this all the way out for our
composition let's see if it loops out it
doesn't because the last frame here
doesn't have an image to look at so if
we back up a frame
add a keyframe there and delete this
keyframe you should be able to see it
maybe we have to do one more spot
another keyframe here over here delete
this keyframe yeah and now we see it
sometimes the loop out function from
time remapping can be a little bit
strange but mostly i just wanted to see
some texture moving here so it looks
like this ufo is rotating so let's go
ahead and scale this down so we'll hit s
for scale and shift p for position and
we're going to set a position keyframe
here
and we're going to scale it down to 50
percent
drag our handle here and at the
beginning here we want it to kind of be
in the shadows right just like the
asteroids are so if i take my z position
and i drag it to the left it's going to
kind of pull it back here into the
shadows
let's bring it up so you can see it
let's keep going back here i want to
make sure
there we go now it's in the shadows i'll
make a little bit more mysterious this
way we're going to go to the end here
four seconds in and we're just going to
make it kind of fly back in z space
maybe
somewhere
over in here
like it's
leaving
maybe it's kind of going down here and
dropping down
let's go back to the beginning here and
we're going to zoom out and we're going
to bring up
so you can see now it's hiding that text
so that's looking pretty cool the one
thing that's really bugging me about
this is that this asteroid here is
staying in the shadows for so long so if
our ship is out of the shadows right
here
theoretically this big black asteroid
should also be out of the shadows here
so this is just a matter of me playing
around with the light
to get it to look a little bit more
realistic so i'm going to do that now by
adjusting the position of the light here
getting it to look a little bit better
maybe that means i need to drop the
light down
and looks like maybe it's more about
just kind of pulling that light back and
then maybe taking that ufo and pushing
it even further back
something like this what's in the
darkness maybe scaling it down even more
and then bring the position up
we're hiding that text
now there's some weirdness happening
right here which we'll get that fixed
here uh probably in the next lesson but
sometimes you get some kind of strange
errors that happen and because we're
getting some weirdness here with the
depth of field i'm going to go ahead and
hit a a and turn off that depth of field
and now things look like they just blend
together a little bit better than they
were
previously i'm also going to take that
ufo and i'm going to move that ufo
position up
and maybe start the ufo a little bit
further down and a little bit further to
the left
so i'm really digging how this is
looking so let's go ahead and wrap up
part two of the series i hope that you
really enjoyed this lesson on creating a
sci-fi b-movie title please let me know
if you have any questions in the
comments i'd love to answer them for you
hit that like button if you enjoyed this
video and please subscribe to this
channel it really helps the algorithm
for people to find this channel if
you're looking to upgrade your design
skill set master the outer style and
execute like a pro i have a course
called stylecraft that you can check out
at motionscience.tv
you can also learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description as always thanks for
watching
my name is cameron and this is motion
science
[Music]
[Music]
you